so man we got it we got to start this
off right you guys start this off with a
per I gotta get a good cat purr I don't
think I got one in me bro I'm all per
doubt how method do you go when you're
gonna be playing rum tum tugger you
hanging out with a lot of cats see you
like inviting your neighbors cats over
and watching them work so I actually
went method with the accent so I spoke a
lot of just my English accent on set so
a lot of the staff was like I didn't
know he was English he's like hey we
actually shot the entire thing in the UK
so it was easy to do it um but yeah I
did method in that way but I also
recorded myself a ton I spent a ton of
time in the mirror it was just a lot to
embody embody a cat yeah who among you
guys you think would be the best cat in
real life like who would be the the
coolest cat that you'd want to actually
have as been coolest cat um I think
it'll be cool to have a bustopher jones
James Corden cat you know I love the fat
suit I think he's absolutely hilarious
but the fast food gets me so like I
would have like up in like a fat okay
what was it was your actually when you
first saw everything come together I
mean it's not 100% complete as of yet
but when you saw yourself actually as
that cat character like were you just
blown away I was blown away man I
remember seeing it for the first time I
was in a gym yeah and I got chills down
my spine it was like this is incredible
I can't believe you know this is life
it's like happening this way finally
yeah it takes me back to the beginning
of my music career you know I feel I
feel that um that that new excitement
you know I'm saying just the nerves that
all things you know all these emotions
come in there you know together he's
kind of reminds me to be in it yeah you
broke the internet very recently with
that picture that you posted have you
have you heard from history on like was
Instagram said to you about like the
policy about why they had a problem with
it or um so yeah it's actually hilarious
um they took it down yeah
and I was like how you gonna take my
photo down I had underwear on knock what
are you doing yeah and they said they
were gonna put it back up but like I was
you know I was having fun with it it's
like a lot of fun so like people were
interviewing me about it and never like
did you have an erection I'm like I
didn't have any they're like did you
have a semi I said well it wasn't cold
out so um the fact that that interview
happened they were like oh now we can't
yeah we can't put it back up all right
cool yeah it's Instagram I love
Instagram and um it's not that serious
yeah yeah do you have to think twice now
when you're like I want to a poses
picture I'm looking good today um nah
man I mean I really put so much thought
you know into into the gram I have a
fabulous photographer that I work with
and yeah we just kind of go with the
flow man yeah do you have a favorite
movie obviously not after cats after
this movie but a favorite movie you
watch growing up that was like a cat's
movie um I forgot what it was called but
there was one cat's movie that I
remembered I was when I was really young
it was like a car a cartoon I liked the
Aristocats no no I mean a note to make
yeah I think Aristocats is before my
time Hey yeah I can't remember the name
but um yeah man I mean I think this this
particular film man is it's the perfect
it's the perfect time for it yeah it's
Christmas time is for the family to go
out there and and just being the Gulf in
another world man it's really cool yeah
it's awesome